uh i want my baby back baby baby baby i
want my baby
back
chili's baby back ribs
i want my baby back baby
baby back ribs
no way out the second one okay
[Laughter]
i look forward to drug testing
i used to get a runner's high
which is why now i lift
chin
i look forward to drug testing
but urinating is not something
andy i need evidence got it wait you
don't know what evidence ah right on yes
hit me next to my desk is a picture of a
female politician bella abzug is that
scary face funny hat gap tooth or bill
clinton's wife funny hat funny hat on
the back of it is a key taped to it and
then that opens my bottom drawer and my
desk get
[Laughter]
what's happening sorry i lost it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's funny okay okay
sometimes when i wipe
i'll wipe and i'll wipe and i'll wipe
and i'll wipe
a hundred times
still poop still poop let me check that
it's like i'm wiping a marker or
something
jean ralphio
[Music]
what's your name again elise yarpton
elaine smarkins
i'm sorry
at least narcans
do that again
sorry
this is not a joke this is not a
carnival
kind of bad
nice job nice work
this is busiest
beaver i know it says busiest no
no you screwed that up didn't you i
guess we have to go back don't we we're
wasting a lot of tape give me that
[Music]
come on phyllis come on
oh jesus are you all right
phyllis are you all right are you okay
i'm okay
don't don't you even
keep that in there oh my god
i think i'm gonna need some new pants
oh my god no
hey jennifer look what we can do
jennifer
jennifer
jeff
jennifer look what we're look what we're
doing
oh really
jennifer he's actually in me
i got it i got it
nice oh yeah
i also got some dude's briefcase i
believed in you buddy
but you should put that back
yeah how did you get this
well what
that is
[ __ ] hilarious you shattered the
lights you shattered it not only did you
hit the welcome heads
that's not something that props can fix
that's gonna be a little harder to fix
i'm sorry i'm out
oh
you broke it
you broke it oh
oh
man this bit will never work
wow
and
this copier
is
working fine that's the original well
[Laughter]
could not have made a better noise
we're having an earthquake get it on the
dvd
yeah rolling rolling on the earthquake
go on the earthquake
i'm so glad i showed you all the trains
going through scranton what happened to
foreign michael it's okay two minutes is
too soon five minutes and two minutes is
a very big difference
[Music]
[Laughter]
man i'm in love with you because you're
just like me
you're a dog take me ann i'm single
[Laughter]
ron you're gonna construct the stage yes
ma'am
i really think we should try and involve
this talking dog
and will you go out on a date with me
you're the prettiest dog i've ever seen
damn remember when we had sex in the
gutter on rodney street i'll never
forget her dad
i'm gonna come over there and [ __ ] you
up
[Laughter]
leslie doesn't like to hear her mommy
talk about sex
no one wants to hear that why don't you
tell us about your escapades you little
minks what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
mr dwyer
were you aware
of funds for tennis court
that ms nope requested that was denied
by mr ron swanson that was later
approved
by ben wyatt
no
do you play tennis
i don't know
are you aware of what tennis is
yeah
what point comes after deuce
wipe
property you're looking at is in great
shape and the equipment's 100 pristine
are you looking to preserve it
whoa whoa something major happened
wasn't my fault installed poorly okay
i know bob vance dwight schrute i work
next door just give him a call
call bob vance call bob vance
bob
just
forget it mr schrute are you looking to
preserve it as a munitions class just
i'll call you back
oh my god
what's your point here's my point
here's the church here's the steeple
open it up
there's all the people cheating on other
people okay do this do this
[Laughter]
i'm gonna go to the bathroom and powder
my nose
amongst other things
if you know what i mean
dude is she gonna powder her vagina
i'm sorry
dude is she gonna powder
[Laughter]
can we just get it on the next steak
yeah yeah okay okay
okay
[Laughter]
a vanilla chain latte for my young
nubian princess
step one
we buy into this club
step two we roll over to the club either
in your mercedes-benz which is gorgeous
or my pre-owned acura legend which is
all right
step three i dagger you on the dance
floor
just bounce bounce bounce
bounce
bounce bounce bounce the bounce now
everybody's watching
i'm so sorry
step three
i dagger you on that dance floor
and dress you with my eyes
until at last it's just me and you naked
on the dance floor
you throw up you're gonna smile
you